السمكة الحجرية هي أكثر
أنواع الأسماك سمية في العالم، وعندما أتيحت لي
الفرصة لأخذ لدغة، وهو
درس مؤلم للغاية، يمكنني أن أضيف أنني فعلت ذلك
لأن هذه الرحلة كانت قد بدأت بالفعل قبل
سنوات من
أن لدغة السمكة الحجرية لم تكن
بالضرورة شيئًا  لقد خططت
أنها نتيجة بدأت منذ سنوات
من خلال اختبار لسعات مخلوقات المحيط الأخرى في
أي وقت نتعمد فيه لدغة
لأغراض التعلم، نقوم بإجراء أبحاثنا،
نقوم بواجباتنا المنزلية، ومن المؤكد أننا
لا نذهب طوعًا أو كرهًا  الخروج إلى
بيئة وتلقي لسعات من حيوانات
لا نعرف شيئًا عنها،
ستكون كما تعلمون Pretty Reckless [
موسيقى]
ما حدث مباشرة بعد لدغة السمكة
الحجرية كان ألمًا فوريًا
تقريبًا يشبه الصدمة الكهربائية التي
شعرت بها في اللحظة التي  السم يكسر الجلد أو
العمود الفقري الذي يكسر الجلد وكان الأمر
تقريبًا بمثابة رد فعل فوري
لسحب يدي بعيدًا وبعد حوالي خمس
دقائق من الحرق بدأت أشعر
بالوخز والأحاسيس،
الأشياء التي أحضرتها معي
بالطبع كانت عبارة عن الإبينفرين  القلم الذي يعد
بمثابة شريان الحياة إذا كان لديك أي
نوع من الحساسية، لذا فهذا
شيء أحمله معي دائمًا في
الميدان بغض النظر عما إذا كنت أعرف أنني
أتعرض للدغة أو أنني في
مغامرة فقط، فهذا شيء جيد  للحصول على
إسعافات أولية، كما أحضرت معي الماء الساخن
إلى الحقل لأن ما
يميز الكثير من الأسماك السامة
بما في ذلك السمكة الصخرية هو أن سمها
يسمى ما يسمى
بالمسؤولية الحرارية مما يعني أن البروتينات الموجودة في السم
يمكن تفكيكها بسهولة عن طريق الحرارة  لكن
يمكنني أن أخبرك في هذه الحالة مع السمكة
الحجرية، أن العلاج بالماء الساخن
أوقف الألم في مساراتها، لكني
كنت أعاني من ألم دائم لعدة أيام،
وعادةً ما يكون العمود الفقري للسمكة الحجرية مغطى
بغمد من الجلد، وعندما تكشف عن
العمود الفقري الأساسي، يكون ذلك  في الواقع، لكن
الكثير من جمهورنا كانوا يطلقون عليه اسم "
جاتوريد بلو" وهو مشروب رياضي وقد
فاجأني حقًا أيضًا،
فهو ليس شيئًا رأيته
من قبل في بحثي، لذلك هناك دائمًا
أشياء تحدث في المحتوى الخاص بنا أو تحدث
عند إنشاء المحتوى الخاص بنا  مقاطع الفيديو التي
تفاجئنا والتي كانت
بالتأكيد واحدة منها
أود أن أقولها بشكل قاطع إنه
لا ينبغي أبدًا أن يلدغك حيوان
كما أفعل أنا أو كما نفعل في Brave
Wilderness أه هناك الكثير من التخطيط
هناك الكثير من  أعتقد أن
هذه التجارب التي نخضع
لها أنفسنا إذا تعرضت للدغة فايرستون،
أنهي بالتأكيد طلب الرعاية الطبية
أه وخذ الأمر على محمل الجد
[موسيقى]
أجنبية